my first guest tonight starring the
insanely popular AMC series The Walking
Dead which returns this fall for season
six please welcome Norman Reedus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome my first question isn't even a
question
you guys must absolutely love it here
this must be the perfect place for you
to go how intense is it I mean what's it
what's your experience at being here
have you walked on the floor have you
been out there I mean these are our
people so we love you guys lat last year
Stephen and I we put on mass I was the
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man and he was
spider-man and we walked around for a
little while but they figured us out how
do they figure you out if you're in a
state Puft Marshmallow outfit I'm a
little pigeon-toed
your fans are really good the angle of
those shoulders I know it's him we're
actually like in full suits I think
which gave it away like just a mass with
full suits on oh that was yeah yeah yeah
idea it said and it said we are the cast
of the one that's here yeah
deny I mean what's your experience of it
been like the fans obviously very
intense loving supportive that's got to
be great they are they're awesome and
it's really cool to actually come we've
worked together and it's like kind of
coy stirred out in like rural Georgia
and we work really hard together with an
amazing crew and we come out in the
leafy oh my gosh she's all the people we
were doing it for yes was very cool and
I saw the ladies I got to give her a
shout out Melissa Johnson she's an
amazing fan just an exhibit of fan love
she gave me one of these really cool
clutches with all like Walking Dead
[Applause]
that's fantastic that's very creative
does it ever go too far though you've
got supportive fans other people that
take it a little far to the point where
you think you got to tone it down yeah
that guy dude that guy yeah I mean I was
on a plane the other day and I got a
sandwich I was running around from set
it got on a plane ate a sandwich but I
was waiting for it to get to to the
level and I pulled out the sandwich
tighter on everyone around me was
videotaping we eat the sandwich so I got
up and ate it in the bathroom of the
plane oh that's disgusting
he was that in the bathroom airplane
eating a sandwich yeah yeah yeah that's
the worst thing I've ever heard
yeah yeah that's such a sad image that
was pretty sad yeah but I mean it was
you know the beginning of the flight it
wasn't that bad you guys have fans that
know where you are going to land on a
commercial flight they find out where
you're gonna land and they routinely
show up so that they're there when you
walk off the plane is that true yeah it
is it is I don't know how it works
someone told me it's cuz he has a friend
on TMZ and I don't know I have some list
they see I don't know come on how did
you know I was flying from Atlanta to
LaGuardia just on two days I have off of
shooting and he finally told me and I
was like okay so it's like okay can um
can you not be here just a couple times
just a couple times so they said okay
and then they weren't there like the
next two times and then the third time
they said see we gave you some time
[Laughter]
you know what's interesting the show
it's a fantastic show very tense a lot
of graphic violence
you have very young fans you guys have
kids that come up to you and say they
love the show oh yeah they come up and
boom they do that well I'm not I get
that too but it's not but my club like
dressed like deny we actually have some
pictures of young just young fans that
like
he's so happy he just ate a brain a
Chuck oh my god and then I love this
next one this is really great
she learned she learned that off of
Darrell sees that night from what our
herons are saying you gotta check this
out when I handle that one there's just
no like there's like weird filters that
are like lost now like social graces
last time I saw a weird kind of weird
fan encounter was in the bathroom right
and this like there's like urinal code
you know what I mean like there's like
dude urinal code which when you walk in
even if you're talking to your buddy
you're not talking to him you're looking
at the wall or like looking at yourself
making sure it's going to the right
place
i'ma look at myself guy Yeah right and
it was like this guy came up to me and
we were peeing and he goes sup man
what's up and he's like I guess I should
tell my friends I'm peeing nice to Glen
right now and then he does the forbidden
move which is that
[Applause]
forbidding move and then you look you
look to the other side Norman's here at
the urinal eating a sandwich yes
[Applause]
more with the Stars walking dead we'll
be right back stick around
[Applause]